[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships George camel Ramsey
personality is my co-host today he's
also the co-host of smart money happy
hour and the host of The George camel
show very popular on YouTube both Ram
Network Productions and we'll be taking
your calls the phone number is
5225 Brian starts this hour in St Louis
hey Brian welcome to the Ramsey
Show hey thanks for the call sure what's
up uh my wife and I are trying to build
a house um and we're discussing how much
we should have saved ahead of time I
would like to have a 100,000 saved and
she wants to start now we're at about
40,000 saved M okay and uh so she isn't
as concerned about the down payment as
you
are uh she's just excited to get
going more so than concerned about the
down payment which you are yeah so what
does the payment process look like for
this build when is all the money
due uh well we haven't started anything
yet um and so I would like to save a
hundred hopefully get 200 out of our
house house and then maybe go 350 total
and then just have 50 left to finish up
when we're all done M what do you make
which we could what your hous so inome
uh about about a hundred okay so you're
talking about a $350,000
build okay and you got 40 how long do it
take you to get to 100 if we want your
way what was your goal uh a little over
a year mhm so we're not arguing about 60
we're arguing about a
year right she want to go now you want
to go in a
year cor okay
um which means that if we go her way you
end up with a $100,000 mortgage not a
$50,000
mortgage yes or $110,000 mortgage to be
precise right am I doing all this
correctly
Brian yes okay how sure are you this
home is going to cost
350 uh not sure that's just the goal
that we'd like to keep under do you have
a
blueprint no we haven't started anything
do you have a
builder we have nothing just discussions
you own the
land uh we have family land set
aside okay uh sidebar before sidebar
before we keep going family land set
aside needs means that there needs to be
a plat that is deeded to
you and and you have the right to sell
it someday if you all don't want to live
there anymore otherwise don't do this
deal right you don't build your house on
Daddy's land or your house on a lot that
Daddy gave you off his land and he says
you can never sell it neither one of
those those are both deal Killers it
would be purchased okay and you would
own it oh wait a minute what does the
land the land is part of the
350 yes okay and then you would have
full rights emotionally relationally
legally to sell it later if you want
to yes okay I don't I I've taken that
call a lot in the last 30 years someone
that's stuck in a piece of property
because everybody's going to be mad if
they sell their own
house right don't do that all right now
all right back to the deal so the land
is how
much uh 40,000 and that's included in
the 350 did you say or not included yes
okay all right we think but we you
really have nothing to base this on
except square foot and you think you're
going to build x square fet I I would
tell you this I'm in the middle of
building a house right now um it took us
nine months from the time we decided we
wanted to to get a blueprint a builder
and a
budget okay completed
completed I mean from day one and I've
done it before so I'm guessing uh that
you can start on the process now and
it's probably going to take you close to
a year then you'll have that 100 yeah or
not I mean you know it may take you nine
months and then you split the difference
right but I I think you can go ahead and
get started because here's what's going
to happen when you start drawing this
house and you actually start talking to
builders and you actually start getting
bids you're going to find out your
numbers are
wrong right or they change and I doubt
they change
down right you got to watch the scope
creep thing here yeah my fear is this
thing is double what you thought it was
going to be and now we got to relook at
is this the right next move or do we
just buy a place yeah I think we got a
you got bigger issues than when when to
start okay you need to go you guys you
can start today on the get looking at
Builders and looking at Blueprints and
getting it dialed in and once all of
that's done if it's not been a year um
and you've got everything dialed in and
you really can still do the numbers that
you come up with the real numbers not
hopeful numbers um
then we can say all right I still don't
want to start then and what I would
recommend back to your original argument
is just split the
difference just you know instead of a
year or starting now uh let's say six
months and by then but it believe me
it's going to be six months at least I
don't think we're starting next week on
this build anyway we're not we got some
time we're not Builders Builders aren't
working as much right now so you
probably can find one that'll give you
some attention that's because of the
rates that's a good thing just slowed
down a little bit very few specs going
up uh if builders that are working are
doing customs and so very few home
starts on specs uh because the Market's
really slow with the high interest rates
um prices have held firm and have gone
up in most cases in depending on the
market but uh the build rate uh new home
starts are down way down way down and
specs have just about disappeared in
most markets wow so which is not a bad
thing it's okay except that the in
except there's no freaking inventory but
for for ran it's a good thing cuz he's
probably going to get some good
attention yeah versus Builder Builder
sub Builder and Subs are going to be
available going a million miles an hour
you don't want someone rushing through
that home build well and you got 73
other clients instead of just you may be
his prized client right now you know
it's possible now on the financing side
how would you suggest Brian go through
with this because there's different ways
when you're working with a builder to
finance it well if it's 50,000 he
probably can go over at the credit union
just get a loan simple if it's going to
be 100 110 150 then he's probably
looking at a formal construction loan
and he'll have to get an appraisal on
the plan the Builder the the general
contractor obviously license will have
to be shown uh to get the appraisal and
then that they'll do that to get and
you'll have to get your approved for
your permanent mortgage and they give
you a letter called a takeout letter
which it means that they will be there
to take out the construction loan at
completion the permanent mortgage will
it'll convert over to a conventional and
you can do all of that with Churchill
Mortgage every bit of that um if you
want to but if you've got a little small
loan like a 50,000 out of 400 or 50 out
of 350 you know probably just your
credit un they'll just make you a loan
like a personal loan almost they're not
going to put a lot of regulation on that
not going to require the takeout letter
not going to require an appraisal not
going to usually but uh but if you get
up there over 100 then you're going to
have a construction loan I just
rewatched The Big Short over the weekend
this whole mortgage crisis man it puts
things in perspective yeah how wild
things were back in those days yeah
well there was just so the big Short's
all about all the fraud that happened
yeah and it was just people making up
appraisals and uh we got a whole new
list of appraisal regulations in as a
result of what happened in that movie
yeah a whole different
world this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100% s
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to save up to
40% off everything sitewide go to
blinds.com for more
[Music]
information
George camel Ramsey personality is our
co-host today open phones at
8825 5225 thanks for being with us
America we're here to serve you our joy
comes when we can show you what to do
and then you actually go do it and it
causes you to win bing bing that's how
that works that's um that's what this
has been about for 30 plus years now and
it continues to be Jody Is With Us in
Springfield Illinois hi Jody welcome to
the Ramsey Show hi there hey what's up I
well I'm kind of embarrassed to ask this
question but I am a
50-year-old Widow who has been widowed
for 15 years
um I have helped put my children through
college and I have no
retirement so I am ready to start
retirement and I don't even know where
to begin and how much to put in there's
nothing embarrassing about any of that
it sounds sounds like you make me feel
good sounds like you're a wonderful
person we just need to get on the ball
right yes yeah so what do you
make I make about I was just sitting
here figuring this out um I bring home
about
36,000 take home a year okay so your
income somewhere around in the low 40s
uh maybe 45 yeah all right what do you
do I am a social worker okay all right
and do you have any
debt I do not your house is paid for yes
that's great
news that means most of your income can
go toward
investing so you have zero saved right
now right what do you have in the
bank well here's what I have I have my
emergency fund of
$1,000 I have my three months I have
three months of my Emer or for my you
know in case something
happens um but that's about all I have
at this point so I'm I'm on the Dave
Ramsey boat I just I'm scared I it's to
a point to where sometimes I cry because
I'm like what am I going to
do you know because I don't know because
when my husband passed away you know I
used like life insurance and all that
kind of stuff to pay my house off so
yeah you know we had a roof over our
head and all that kind of stuff because
my kids were seven and 10 when all of
this happened wow well you've had a lot
of Life happen hard I totally understand
had a lot we're not here to beat you up
we want to give you some good next steps
to take and if you're following the baby
steps now that puts you at baby step
four because you have no debt fully
funded emergency fund and really it's
step seven because you have a paid for
house and so now the kids are they
schools paid for we got to put our own
mask now uh put our own mask on and that
looks like investing for retirement as
aggressively as possible do you have a
retirement plan through your
employer here's what I have and I I
didn't know what route to go but there's
a 403b
okay I don't know much about that I've
kind of looked you know do they have a
match no okay I would not do that then I
would first do okay I mean I may do some
there but we would first do a Roth
IRA okay just a plain Roth not a
traditional a Roth a Roth so what I want
you to do is go to Ramsey solutions.com
and click on smartvestor and get a
smartvestor pro in your area to sit down
with you and they can help you run some
calculations
okay now let me give you an example you
bring home $3,000 a month you do not
have any bills except survival bills you
have no debt no rent no nothing okay
correct if you were to save
invest
$11,000 a month for 15 years at 65
you're going to have right around a half
a million dollars right around
$500,000 really
yeah okay what this means is not that
you're rich and it's really not enough
but it's enough to make sure you're not
cold and
hungry right because it will produce
then let's just let's just reverse
engineer this which is very interesting
okay let's pretend It produced 10% a
year on the mutual funds after that and
that you retired and had no retirement
income and I suspect you probably have a
retirement with your govern government
agency don't you that they furnish
you a
pension uh yeah actually uh my husband I
get a pension off of him but that's
thing but do you get a pension from your
work when you
retire no huh okay it's a social
security I pay into yeah yeah absolutely
which is nothing which is horrible but
that's okay all right so if you had a
half a million at 65 or 67 or whatever
and it was invested at
10% 10% of 500,000 is 50,000 a year
right without touching the nest egg
without touching the goose it will lay
50,000 golden eggs a
year wow and so you'd actually be making
more retirement than you are
now so no kitty so you're going to be
okay that's the point you're not going
to be rich but even if I'm if my numbers
are off a little bit and they might be
one way or another actually probably are
off in this case because you probably
will not be making 36,000 for the rest
of your life you'll probably be making
more and so you could invest probably
more later
agreed right yeah so the I did that
based on $1,000 in your current income
so so I want you to sit down with a
smart Vestor Pro and we don't know how
the scenarios will compare to actual
life but you can run some scenarios like
I just did just to get the idea that I
don't have to
cry cuz if you'll start now Jody and
you'll start investing close to $1,000
or more than $1,000 a month you get your
budget tight and you do that you're
going to be
okay matter of fact you're gonna be
better than
okay that makes me that makes me cry
just being happy yeah so I want you to
sit down but it also needs to make you
get on the budget and do it it also mean
means you to get on the phone and get on
with those smart Vestor pros and go sit
down with them and learn and let's get
this stuff started not next week not
next year now now okay right now it and
because every day you put this off it
gets harder if you put it off a year
it's GNA take
1,200 yeah don't put it off anymore you
put it off as long as you can the fuse
is burning so I want you scared enough
that I scare you into action but I don't
want you terrified anymore so you're
paralyzed I got it I'm on it I'm doing
it today I love you you're awesome call
us back and let us know how it's going
okay okay thank you guys so much I
appreciate it thank you sweet lady love
that she just needed a little motivation
that she's not doing as as bad as she
thought she was and the time to start is
today what's interesting about what we
do for a living we talk about getting
out of Deb or we talk about Building
Wealth numbers actually give you a
result that gives you hope when you run
math okay you know got $100,000 in debt
I'm never going to get out what it's
33,000 a year for for 3 years I mean
it's 2,600 bucks a month and you make
150,000 shut your winding up you know
all of a sudden the numbers give you Ma
give you hope right the math gives you
hope in her case it's $1,000 a month and
for for the next 15 years and not
missing a month and getting started
immediately and getting good returns and
good mutual funds which probably that
403 b does not have that's why I
directed her away from that you know
let's go first to the Roth IRA with more
control more options lot better options
a lot better mutual fund option out
there now I can be off and if y'all want
to argue with my numbers that's fine
argue with my numbers but here's the
point get with it you know and and you
know I might be if I'm half wrong she's
still going to have 25 $26,000 a month
coming in uh or 25 $26,000 a year coming
in uh versus nothing which your little
plan you critique critic people out
there creates nothing that's what
critics create nothing well the new one
Dave is well a million dollars isn't
enough enough anymore Dave that means a
half million dollar is half of not
enough but it's more than you got if you
be broke and crying about it hello yeah
we'd love for you to have multiple
Millions but I mean in this case you
could see 500,000 would still change
your life the way she the only way she's
going to get to over a million is she's
going to raise her income substantially
so she could invest twice as much cuz
2,000 a month yeah for 15 years at 12%
my mutual funds have average 12% for
Less 30 years my personal portfolio and
I'm not a genius
the market is average 11.8% in the S&P
so by God shut up and go do it you know
so could you could you end up with a
million dollars in 15 years yeah it's
two grand a month that's it roughly I
mean there it is ding ding this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
cust loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with why
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumps
some payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y refi.com
[Music]
Ramsey
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
8825 5225 so our team handed me this
this is cool George in March Andrew came
and did a debt-free scream with me and
uh Dr John deloney was on the air and we
celebrated him paying off
$33,000 49 months wow his student loans
car debt home improvement loan credit
card and house paid off his home and and
then we get an email from him that he
had a chance to go back to his Alma moer
his high school to one of our
foundations in personal finance classes
warshaw high school and uh his he he put
this quote on Facebook 2009 whs grad oh
this what they put on there Andrew
returned to his Alma moer today to chat
with the senior financial planning class
about his financial journey and becoming
debt-free he completed the Dave Ramsey
class and paid off his debt this class
is also completing the high school
version of Financial Peace University
thanks for coming Andrew which is called
foundations in personal finance very
cool what a great poster child these
kids are going oh this I got to watch
another video and then they're seeing
this guy who was from their High School
who who graduated from the same sat at
the same desk they set who has no
payments in the world yeah at a very
young age 100% debt free wow ding ding
ding ding house and everything and go in
and tell the high school seniors it can
be done that's how we do it some social
proof yeah we've got the foundations and
personal finance High School curriculum
that now 6 million students have been
through since we started it it's been in
48% of the high schools it's currently
in like 40% of the high schools and more
and more states are now making personal
finance mandatory I love it and so we've
been adopted by for instance the Texas
um what whatever the Texas state school
board or the adoption process to adopt
the curriculum
uh and we were just adopted in uh
Florida oh that's right a couple months
ago a big one so Florida's got a big
push brand new push it's Texas has had
it for a while and they've got their
second push coming to get all the
seniors before they graduate through our
kids before they graduate at some point
as a senior or Junior whatever through a
personal finance curriculum and we have
the largest most successful one and
Florida just adopted ours as well now
they've got other brands that they can
do but so now each of the school local
school boards are selecting whether
they're going to use Ramsey or whether
they're going to use something else but
really excited about it and um um happy
to be in Florida thanks Florida we
appreciate you and actually I got to
meet uh the state senator uh when we
were down there doing an event in
Orlando remember that I got to you were
in the you met him too he's in the Green
Room it was incred and that sponsored
the bill that got passed in Florida to
uh make personal finance a mandatory a
man it's not elect a mandatory class for
graduation at a certain date in Florida
high schools and that precipitates then
the uh High School curriculum or our
personal finance curriculum is getting
adopted and we're one of the high school
approved adopted curriculums in in
Florida so excited about that so if
you're around one of the uh Florida uh
School boards or you're a teacher or
whatever um and you want to push for our
curriculum being in your school we would
appreciate it and way to go Andrew
thanks for going back to your school and
I don't know where washaw High School is
but it's not on this but it's pretty
cool that a guy does that and goes back
and speaks to the class with well
everyone go they don't teach us stuff in
school we do now yeah it's it is in a
bunch of the states now and we're that's
obviously have been doing it a very very
long time very successfully we meet all
the benchmarks it's a we've got a educ
Ramsey education Solutions Department
here that we've been running for I don't
know almost 20 years now and the guys
and gals in that department that that
put this curriculum together that we use
in the high schools uh are from the
education world and so our stuff meets
is the easiest for teachers to operate
because it's the lesson plans are done
the testing is done right it's all built
out to where it's as low lift as
possible former teachers going I wish
this is how it was created I wish
everything was created this way because
our guys are putting and it meets all
the educational benchmarks and
legalities and so forth that we have to
meet in order to be in a a public school
system and so we do every bit of that
and uh man we're just thrilled thrilled
so many people are getting able to do
this and this is cool that Andrew Andrew
did that that's a lot of fun Isaac is
with us Isaac is in Huntsville Alabama
hi Isaac welcome to the Ramsey
Show thanks for having me how are y'all
better than we deserve what's
up so my wife and I are fixing to be
going through our first
divorce and um she's going to keep the
house that we currently have and than to
a wonderful support system I'm going to
be able to move back in with my parents
while I get back on my feet and at this
point I'm just
wondering you know kind of what's next
how do I start over from here what
should be the correct Step I
Take how old are you
sorry I am 32 years old how long are
y'all
married uh about five years or so maybe
you have
children uh a 5-year-old son
yes I'm
sorry huh what do you
make um $33 an hour about $4,000 take
home a month
okay
um well to answer your
question you know you're you're just
going to start laying out a game plan to
build enough financial life that you
move into into this next chapter right I
mean first goal would be to get on your
feet enough that you had a little bit of
money saved and you go get an apartment
right right I mean this obviously your
parents are providing a a safety net not
a
hammock correct and so you're just
passing through and uh like you said
that's a wonderful thing and I'm not
upset about that at all but I would give
myself a number of months like three or
six months or something and say by then
I'm going to have enough save to to have
deposits and get an apartment get my own
place get some furniture you know get
get restarted in terms of like almost as
if you were moving out after high school
or college right right and um and then
you you know once you've kind of got a a
standard of living set and a place to
live then you start doing the baby steps
and you make sure you're you get out of
debt you build an emergency fund and you
know you start investing and you know
you're going to figure out that there's
another chapter to this after 32 years
old right right yeah so this setback is
going to be a comma not a coma so keep
that in your mind this is temporary
you're going to have a whole another
life on the other side of this thing
this isn't Define you but it will refine
you and so now is the time to make some
choices that will set us up for the next
10 years so do you know as the dust
settles what the financial picture looks
like as far as child support alimony the
house
debt so
I will be taking the car that she's
currently driving and she's going to
take the car that I'm currently driving
because it's paid off and the car that I
will be getting is not I owe somewhere
around 21,000 on it um the way we've
worked everything out between us you
know everything's very
amicable so we're it's going to be
uncontested so the way we have it worked
out no child support no alimony or
anything it's all going to be and we
both put in everything we can for him
and she's keeping the house and there's
no you're not getting any money out of
this out of the house
deal correct okay okay I'm not a lawyer
and I'm certainly not a lawyer in
Huntsville Alabama I don't think a judge
is going to approve a divorce decree
that does not in child include child
support okay uh you probably need some
legal advice not to create a stink but I
think you're going to be under the law
in Most states required to do something
for the kids
from a legal perspective I know you were
going to from a moral perspective but um
but I I think I I don't know I don't
know what I'm talking about so you need
to check that out cuz I had fireworks go
off in my head but it can't just be
handshake agreements I don't I don't
think it can be I I you you check me out
I could be wrong okay so um the
house what's the payment on the
house uh 550 a month what does she
make um bring home is about 2,000 a
month okay she's G to struggle with
that and your name still and your name's
still on the mortgage and if you try to
have a new life 5 years from now and she
hasn't paid the bills on time then your
credit is going to have been damaged so
I'm not sure this is a great plan
brother I know it sounds like it's all
nice it's all nice until it's not and
then when she gets in trouble loses her
job you're going end up paying the house
payment for somebody you ain't married
to anymore cuz you're still on the
mortgage this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home buyer Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus a $5,000 seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to Churchill
mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
88255 225 you jump in we'll talk about
your life and your
money Johnny is with us in Irvine
California hi Johnny welcome to the
Ramsey
Show hi there thank you for taking my
call how are you guys better than we
deserve what's up great well I'm calling
to see what you guys would do if you
were in my shoes I'm 22 years old I
fully support myself I take home about
$5,000 per month I have zero debt I have
$60,000 in savings a $3,000 emergency
fund and I've been listening for the
past year or so and some of my friends
and mentors are into long-term real
estate investing so I've been saving
towards that for the past couple of
years ideally I'd like to start building
some long-term wealth wealth and so I
just wanted to see what you guys would
do if you were in my shoes wow you are
beyond beyond ahead of the game well
done very well done thank you well I um
probably have a different view on real
estate investing than your
mentors sure and I probably own more
than they
do given that I own about 600 million
worth okay um but anyway the uh uh I I I
do not believe in borrowing money Johnny
because you and you've heard that
listening to the show and I don't for my
real estate investing I pay cash for it
and so the first real estate investing I
did and I've always loved real estate um
that I did after going broke and
starting completely over and with this
new I don't borrow money thing uh as a
part of the guidelines uh was I didn't
do real estate investing at first I just
started piling money in mutual funds and
when I got enough in in an in in an
index fund is what I used an S&P 500
Index Fund when I it took me about five
years to buy my first income producing
property I paid cash for it and then I
took all of those
rents net of expenses and any other
money I could and I threw it in an index
fund until I had enough to buy another
property and then I took all the rents
from the two properties and any money I
could scrape together from anywhere else
book royalties or whatever else and I
bought another property for cash and
every time I bought another property for
cash I had more cash flow to buy another
property
faster than I did the one before does
that make any sense yeah that that makes
perfect sense that is a very long-term
play versus what you have been
considering until this phone call sure
because you're thinking about getting up
a down payment and going buying a nice
little duplex in
California exactly yeah and I'm telling
you to wait and pay cash for it which
your friends aren't going to like and I
don't really care they're wrong that's
true but you called knowing you were
going to get a different take which
tells me you're actually interested in
this
take I am yeah i' I've just been curious
what to do because I feel like I've I've
been saving decently and I'd like to
continue that um but you know once you
get a certain amount of money I feel
like it burns a little bit of a hole in
your pocket you're ready to jump into it
yeah and you've done really well Johnny
I mean let's face it you're 22 years old
you have ,000 bucks in the in the bank
and no debt at all and you're making 5K
a month you're killing it ding D very
impressive and it doesn't sound like you
lead a super luxurious lifestyle you're
a
saver I I try to be for sure there's
there's a balance so the key is to keep
living on less than you make what would
be interesting if you want to be really
nerdy I don't know how nerdy you are I'm
real nerdy is and I've done this a
couple of times it's and it it always it
always works that's why I'm putting you
up to it is if you say all right when
I'm
42 would I rather own $10 million worth
of real estate with $8 million worth a
debt or would I rather own $3 million
worth of paid for Real
Estate yeah I think the clear answer is
the 3 million yeah and then here's
what's here's the here's the exercise
run out the the purchase snowball which
is not a debt snowball but the way I
talked about a while ago rents buy more
buy more buy more more by more
everything's folded back into the next
deal and the slower start ends up with a
faster
end the faster start ends up with a
slower
end my way is slower start but has a big
time payoff at the end because it hockey
sticks from an exponential mathematical
equation perspective does any of that
make
sense yeah it definitely it does cuz
when you get all this property that's
sitting there paid for you you are
buying more property faster than you
would have if you had a whole bunch of
property that's not even close to paid
for and it's not cash flowing nearly as
generously so the math says I can buy I
can buy more property faster now it's
ridiculous what my real estate fund now
looks like from my real estate
income you now CU I'm at the back of the
story right so but I can't get people to
to think long term
and I might have just got one 22y old to
do it though who know I'm impressed he
sounded interested yeah we could just
get off Tik Tok we'll get there for real
Jake is in De Mo Iowa hi Jake how are
you hey guys it's an honor to speak with
you thanks for having me our pleasure
how can we help sir yeah so I'm 35 years
old have no debt and am about to step
into baby step six and my question is uh
you talk about uh baby step seven living
and giving like no one else I have no
problem with the the giving aspect of
things the part that is a little tricky
for me to wrap my mind around is the
living like no one else because uh I am
a pastor and so to be stepping into baby
step seven hopefully here in the next
five or six years I'm trying to imagine
life in my 40s living like no one else
while being a pastor and and living in
the community of people who uh who pay
for who have paid for my uh financial
success you could say I I don't know how
else you you would put it but how how
should I think through that as I look
forward to the next five or 10 years
yeah well
um don't muzzle the ox as he Treads out
the grain you probably read that
scripture right yeah and a worker is
worthy of his
hire you probably read that scripture
right M so are you a good pastor and
you're worth what they pay you
you I I sure hope so then if you use
that money wisely in Christianity we
would call that good stewardship
wouldn't
we I think you're modeling for those
people what good Steward what the
results of good stewardship are that it
ends up with
wealth but we're taught by
the by Carl Marx not by Jesus that
wealth is
evil wealth is not evil people are evil
evil particularly some of them in your
church I'm kidding
no but but uh not much but yeah
anyway but yeah but but so you're always
goingon to have a hater whether you win
or you lose if you do it at
scale yeah if you lose you weren't a
good Steward and you're horrible and you
worked your whole life and you have
nothing to show for it and we call that
being a good Steward that's not a good
Steward that means you did a bad job
hand Ling your
money so you're supposed to model for
your congregation how to how to be a
good husband how to be a good dad right
right how to be a great leader we're
supposed to model in Christian it's
called a witness we call And yet when it
my my friend Craig Rochelle says why is
it that wealth is the only blessing from
God we're supposed to apologize
for and I've got several friends that
are pastors that are uh a decade and a
half ahead of you and they're facing the
exact same thing cuz they have
systematically carefully invested in uh
in their 401ks and in their Roth IRAs
and in their retirement programs and
some of them are bought real estate
carefully and they they don't have jet
airplanes they're not on TV you know
that it's none of that junk they're just
good guys as a pastor and they've been
careful with their income and most of
them are millionaires because they did
the stuff I teach but now there's always
some duber that says well Pastor should
never be a millionaire yeah that's what
I want I want my pastor to be broke and
stupid no I don't either I want my P I
don't want I want you know Pastor should
never listen I want my pastor I want his
marriage to be something I can look up
to I want his kids to be something I can
look up to I want the way he handles
money to be something I can look up to
because obviously the book he is reading
has having an effect on his life and I
want to know more about what that book
called The Bible says then but not if
you're out you know so but you're always
going to be criticized Jake whether it's
about your message or the car you drive
there going to be someone out there ex
and you know you have to get if you're a
Christian you have to drive a used a
cord cuz that's what Jesus said they
were all in one Accord oh that one still
gets me this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey George camel here if you love
the show and you want a deeper dive on
your money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsey Way just go to ramsy
solutions.com today to sign up for the
newsletter again that's ramsy
solutions.com to sign up for our Weekly
[Music]
Newsletter
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships open phones at
5225 that's
5225 Jenna start oh George camel Ramsey
personality is my co-host today uh he's
also the co-host of smart money happy
hour and the host of The George camel
show on YouTube which is exploding by
the way one of our more popular Ramsay
Network launches in the last year Jenna
is with us Jenna is in Seattle
Washington hi Jenna welcome to the
Ramsey Show hi oh my gosh I'm so excited
to talk to you guys you too what's
up um so I have a situation that feels
complicated to me but likely not to you
guys which is why I'm calling um I am
the soulle provider for my family and am
self employed as a um therapist a mental
health therapist in private practice and
um I make uh good money over $200,000 a
year and am um yeah over 10 years it's
been it's been amazing um but um I'm
paid pretty irregularly mostly by
insurance companies and um I usually
know by like Sunday evenings um kind of
what my deposits are going to look like
but they tend to um be slight slightly
different um each week and then I also
get kind of random payments like you
know co- payments from patients or just
um kind of paper checks it's just I'm
not I don't have like a it's sort of
predictable but like also not
predictable long you been doing
this uh how long have I been doing this
over 10 years uh actually so over the
over the course of a year it's very
predictable over the course of 6 months
it's fairly predictable over the course
of one week it's not
correct okay so give us some uh R estim
what's your question so we're struggling
to budget um as far as um the kind of
grocery shopping um weekly versus
monthly like just kind of really trying
to understand our money better um we've
kind of banked on like we just make good
money and so we money just sort of
disappears and I'm trying to do better
we're trying my husband and I are trying
to do better um I had one caveat
question I wanted to throw him under the
buses he also refuses to drop the coffee
stand and wants to keep it in the budget
and I want to mix it from the budget um
so I want you guys to give me some uh
you mean buying a cup of coffee at a
coffee stand correct this is not your
problem no it's not my problem you need
to lose that battle and win the war he
needs a budget line item for his coffee
he gets his coffee and we get a budget
together that we both work on that
accomplishes our overall goals coffee is
not keeping you from doing that I agree
all right that one's under the bus he
you lose he wins next all right George
how do we do an irregular income so the
simplest way to look at this is look at
what a low month would be for you guys
we know it's not going to be zero right
correct so what would be a low
month a low month would be 12,000 okay
so we start there we'll input that in
the budget and when more money comes in
we'll just add that income into the
budget on the income side got me okay
yes then on the expense side we're going
to do it a little differently because
it's a regular we're going to make a
prior prioritized spending plan so let's
have our four walls we got to cover the
bills you know the rent the mortgage all
of that stuff first food on the table
you should have a set food budget that
is fixed that easily fits within
$112,000 and it should not have to
change based on the irregularity of the
income okay other things will change
based on the irregularity but not food
okay because it's first now are you at
risk of running out of money even on
that bad month of $122,000 or are you
just trying to go hey we should be
saving more with all of our expenses
well um no we're not at risk of running
out of money um I just don't feel like
we're throwing enough at our snowballs
um we have perect perfect yeah we're not
at risk of running out of money as far
as our our needs go I just feel like it
every after that it sort of just
disappears gotcha but it's not
disappearing into the coffee stand
there's other places other money leaks
well it's what she's saying I think and
I don't put words in your mouth is it's
disappearing into the disorganization
ization and the chaos and I want to get
a handle on this so I can feel like I'm
doing a good job correct like it's like
one week I'll I'll pay the Comcast bill
and then the next week I'll pay you know
a different bill and I just don't feel
like I'm organized enough um and so I
feel like you know I want to have a
better understanding and I was thinking
similar to what you were saying if I
just created an idea budget and then
whatever kind of comes extra I could
even just throw out our snowball um if
you can live on the
12,000 without touching it and you get
everything you need to do you could run
a budget on 12,000 and every extra
dollar above that goes to your debt
snowball that's an easy
fix okay if you need 13,000 to live but
12 is your low then you've got to add a
th000 to those last few things before
you start the de snowball that's what
George is saying yeah so including our
business expenses we need about $9 ,000
to live 9 to 10,000 to live okay your
business needs to be running
separately yeah yeah yeah yeah the
business is running separately um
household no no no noop STP STP you
don't have an included okay the it's not
it's not running separately if it's
included hello so here here's the thing
we run a business budget and then when
we bring money home from our net profits
after paying the business
expenses then we work with that so your
business expenses run
what my business expenses are monthly is
only uh $2,300 a month okay all right so
you actually have a low of
9700 yes because you're not bringing
home that
2300 correct okay so you know so so that
based on what we're doing I need to have
you need to have that separated out and
keep it set completely separate run a
separate set of book separate checking
account separate everything for the
business we actually give ourselves a
weekly paycheck we give ourselves that
doesn't matter you got to you got and
then you need to cash out the rest of
the profits beyond your weekly paycheck
and beyond your expenses out of the
business account over into the personal
account but the same principle will
still work because the same math applies
I just split it aparts all okay so
you're still okay 9700 will still do it
if 2,300 stayed at the office you can
still do it on 9700 and everything else
will go to the de snowball and then sign
so in the 9700 some of it's going to the
debt snowball but it's just how much
more we put on the debt snowball and
every every dollar premium will cause
you to be able to do that we've got a
thing in there called paycheck planning
uh that works really well for the
irregular income and you and your
husband can sit down together and lay
the whole thing out on the app uh or on
the desktop whichever you choose to do
with every dollar and it'll lay all out
and and we'll give you three months free
and get you started on the every dollar
premium okay a awesome cool thank you
guys all right hang on um we'll have the
team pick up and give you three months
for every dollar premium because that'll
that'll do it perfectly oh yeah and
it'll help him see where's all this
money going what did we decide we were
going to do this month yeah and then the
only choice you're making is $8 or
whatever the flipping coffee is it's
ridiculous but I mean $8 is not going to
get you out of debt that or but but you
are going to start looking at everything
including the coffee you'll see how much
money you're wasting how much more can
we throw how far are we going to cut our
lifestyle versus the debt we have versus
the $200,000 well not really
$175,000 income that we have this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
shot
hey guys I've told you before about
Christian healthare Ministries a health
cost sharing Ministry but listen to
Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that with
chm she can help other families who need
it and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that's her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones
I was just telling George a story and
Austin you need to hear this too in 2012
I took a call here on the air from a guy
who had a side hustle and he said I love
my side hustle more than I like my job
when can I quit my job and do the side
hustle I want to double down my parents
say I'm crazy for doubling down my wife
says I'm half crazy for quitting my job
uh he was a pharmacist so he'd spent a
lot of money and a lot of time getting
to to be a pharmacist he he said I want
to quit Pharmacy I want to go into this
whole other side of things in the gun
industry and I'm like okay so I'm I'm a
gun guy so I'm talking to him and
listening to him I'm like yeah that's
pretty cool so I said how much do you
make and he said I made 65,000 on my
side hustle how much you make as a
pharmacist this year this is 2012 he
said 60,000 I said well double down I'm
on your team uh I if I would advise your
wife that you should go after this it's
what you love it's your passion I would
advise your mom and dad that they're
very sweet but they're wrong and that
you should go after this
so um a couple weeks ago I was out west
and um I visited the guy's
business he did 70 million last
year that hurts my
brain wow and he acts like I did it and
I'm like I didn't do anything I talked
to you for five minutes you've worked
for uh you know what 11 12 years on your
business you built your business I
didn't build your business I'm so so
proud of you though uh I I'll take
credit for lighting a fire but dude you
you you burned the forest down man that
is way to go way to go man that's pretty
cool uh we don't always get to hear the
followup 11 years later to taking some
of you guys' calls out here so uh some
of you ought to tell us if we screwed it
up 12 years later or if we got we got it
right or whatever yeah goodness pretty
cool for pretty cool I'm I'm impressed
with him sharp young guy too obviously
Todd is in Fort Wayne hey Todd welcome
to the Ramsey Show hey Dave thanks for
taking my call sure what's up got a
quick question for you uh back in 2009
2010 when there's a big recession that
we all heard about my business uh went
in pretty deep and uh since then I've
paid back uh everybody I can and taking
care of all that but I've got one credit
card that went after me and in 2000
through Collections and uh it took me to
small I guess you call it small claims
court because I seen I got a letter for
a judge judgement against me but at that
time um I was still trying to get my
head above water how long ago was the
Judgment uh it was 2015 August of 2015
eight years ago okay was the first one
yes uh the first one yeah the amount was
about um I don't know $2 $3,000 but of
course with all their fees that judgment
was for $8,000 round numbers and uh
anyway I just got another certified
letter today I didn't know how to for
sure uh how to contact these guys I just
knew it was out there but they've added
2,000 to it um anyway it says they have
14 days to congest um I'm assuming a
court hearing I didn't know the first
time I could do that but do I just I
don't think they I don't think they get
to have a court hearing on this one okay
because it's gone too long yeah all
right so let's do a little uh let's
learn a couple things here number one
you owe these people some money and
you're not disputing that agreed yes
okay yes and the original balance was
what uh I don't know for sure it was
like 3,000 or something with their fees
the original no I'm talking about fees
I'm talking about what you actually owe
them oh the first one was uh $79.97 so
8,000 no no no no no no that was with
the
fees okay when you had a credit card
before it went to collections the
balance on the credit card was $3,000
wasn't it yeah somewhere around there
yeah that's what I'm thinking okay
so um here's the thing if they said
they've added more another 2,000 so it's
now $10,000 right yes okay there's a
whole industry out there that most
people don't even know is out there
called debt
buyers and they buy old
bad probably
uncollectable debt probably
uncollectible because the person has
already filed bankruptcy and they don't
get anything but they still will buy the
debt sometimes not knowing that uh or
the debt has gone too long and it's
passed the statute of limitations in
that county or that City or that town or
that state and so it's not collectible
which I think is probably the case with
yours anyway they probably get zero uh
technically legally uh but they buy old
bad debt now let me tell you what they
pay for
it a nickel on the
dollar maybe less yeah so this guy
calling you or certified lettering you
is with a $10,000 bill likely has $250
to $500 invested in your
account
okay that's good information if you're
going to call him and offer him 3,000
bucks yeah I want to do right by this
debt I'm willing to pay $3,000 that's
all I'm willing to pay if you want $1
more I'm going to give that to a lawyer
and I'm going to fight you to the death
cuz I don't think you can collect this
at all cuz it's gone too long
so this is a case this letter from the
our County Courthouse or uh Court does
that make a difference nope it's not the
court didn't buy the debt some duber
bought the debt okay so the dubers
brought you to the county courthouse you
got a is a duber name on
there uh yeah the collection agency and
there's a lawyer name on it the lawyer
is who you call call the lawyer okay cuz
here's the deal they are not in the
business this is not like if I owe you
money and you were pissed and got a
lawyer and sued me okay this is a
conveyor belt at a factory and it's the
junkyard it's not even a factory it's a
conveyor belt at the junkyard and
they're running like 9,000 Parts a
minute down the conveyor belt and you're
one tiny little
part okay all right let me give you
another example just to for fun okay a
couple of Christmases ago I decided to
take advantage of this colge to do a fun
charitable thing for our team we bought
8,000 accounts from a debt buyer
totaling $10 million worth of debt our
purpose in buying it was we were going
to call all 8,000 people we have a th000
employees so each of them got to call
eight people and tell them their debt is
Forgiven in Jesus name for
Christmas so we bought $10 million worth
of debt to do that for
$259,000 2.5 cents on the
dollar yeah that's amazing yeah so I'm
telling you this is how this works so
that that's who you're dealing with
you're one of 8,000 in a
package only you didn't the package
wasn't bought by me so you got to go
deal with the people but it's still I
had
8,000 people that were in this one
package for two and a half cents on
2.59 cents on the dollar
all right and that that's how this
that's how this industry works man so
and what do they want they want more
than they've got in it because this is a
business for them not a charitable event
so they got 250 or 500 Grand $500 in
your deal you offer them 3,000 and you
stand firm and argue with them about 30
times they're going to take it get it in
writing do not give them electronic
access to your checking account those
two things are very
important okay so I think you should pay
them what you owe them which is three
grand okay you got the three grand yep I
do very cool does that does that tell
you what you need to know yes perfect
thank you cool thank you so they're
hoping a few people in this giant pile
will pay that eight or 10 grand to make
this whole operation work no they they
never get
it 99% of the accounts aren't
collectible that's why they're worth
nothing because I mean what do you what
are the chances of collecting on
something from 2010 13 years ago 13
years ago if you can even find the guy I
mean they're just saying Glory
Hallelujah that they even found him
right we had trouble making the calls we
couldn't even old cell phone numbers bad
numbers we had a we you know we had what
I bet you uh one out of uh one out of
eight was probably bad or two out of
eight the information we had with the
accounts we bought were bad which tells
you they had bad information when they
bought it well yeah cuz it's old I mean
how many people got the same cell phone
number 13 years later you know and or
whatever the same address and you know
you don't send a change of address to
people you owe money to if you're on the
run you know so it doesn't happen that
way so it's an interesting world but
it's a very high doll high number low
performance world and if you'll keep
that in mind when you're dealing with
them it's not personal it's just a
transaction for them this is the Ramy
[Music]
show
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
88255 225 today's question of the day
sponsored by neighborly your home for
home your hub for Home Services
neighborly can help you find local
service pros like the Grounds Guys
five-star Painting and More to get your
outdoor space ready for the cooler
months download the neighborly app today
and get started today's question comes
from Steve in Minnesota I'm 43 years old
I still have student loan debt about
4,900 it was originally 24 Grand back in
2010 this year in May I went and got
2,130 hair graph transplants for about
13 Grand some I paid up front and the
rest I used a Care Credit Card for
$10,500 I owe about five grand on it now
I have 32,000 in savings I've got about
10 grand on a 401K and I make about 20
bucks an hour I didn't get enough hair
graphs to cover the back top crown area
should I go back for more hair
transplant graphs to cover that
area Dave this is a personal question
that I think only you could
answer this is very personal it's
personal you're just mean hair jokes
George Well you bullied me for far too
long day it's my time to get
back oh Steve Steve Steve okay Steve
Steve well the good news is Steve has
some money and he can clean up this debt
today I don't know why he's waited 13
years he has 30 2 Grand in savings let's
knock out the 10 grand in debt and
you'll still have 22,000 left that
covers an e emergency fund and that
should cover some hair graphs so 32,000
10,500 on the credit card he says he
owes five on it now and then um oh okay
and then five so so 10,000 clears up the
student loan and the card right yep and
that leaves him
$22,000 right mhm that's what I'm saying
okay and um then we need to ascertain
what your emergency fund should be 3 to
6 months of
expenses and if that is under
$22,000 like say 15 then you would have
seven you could use towards other things
and if that's what you choose to do with
your money
okay um right yeah but if your if your
emergency fund should be
25,000 you need to finish your emergency
fund before you do other things because
until you're out of debt and have an
emergency fund in place we do not
do elective surgeries that's a luxury
it's a luxury well I need bigger
lips no no the food's going in you don't
need bigger lips the uh coffee is not
spilling you need bigger you don't need
bigger lips uh you can bigger lips are a
luxury uh hair in the back is a luxury
apparently here in the front is a luxury
for so he must have got just the front
done and then he's got this Crown here
that's still
I mean if you're the hair transplant
people that was genius hey you'll have
to come back it leaves you it leaves you
with a a guaranteed client for the back
as soon as they get home and get a
mirror the other question is they do a
good job with the rest of it so far cuz
maybe let's not go back my stomach is in
my throat this is killing me but yeah
but I imagine it's a few more Grand to
finish it up if he's got the crown left
I don't I'm going to get in a lot of
trouble if I'm not real careful here but
anyway the um yeah if this is what you
want to do with your money it should
only be done it's a choice it's a luxury
item it's like buying a new couch or
upgrading a car it's done after your
emergency fund is in place and you are
debt free so you should write a check
today Steve and pay off your student
loan debt and your credit card I'm is
this even is this real this is real some
guy spook I thought Austin was trolling
us somebody's punking us and Austin let
it through it's too specific to be
punking at this point well it's a good
way to to somebody You' give great
detail like I just don't have enough
hair graphs in the he told us how many
hair graphs
2,130 I know but that's pretty that's
how you punk somebody that's how that's
what causes us to bite on it well we bit
on it and so we're pretending like it's
real I think someone wanted to know your
take on hair transplant oh that's just
no no they didn't obviously they know my
take on hair transplant all they got to
do is just pull up Pi say not worth the
money well it's just um it's
a yeah you've been cutting your own hair
for a few decades now it's easier that
way the amount of money you've saved
though compared to me I just grew up in
a different place and a different time
where we enjoyed getting old and we is
what we is so we didn't constantly be
poking and prodding at ourselves but
it's a different time back then it was
just like a tou pay there weren't many
options yeah that's true it's a bad two
pay or nothing yeah like something out
of a movie from the 70s yeah but oh I
don't I I figured that the person with
the lowest hair maintenance and the
highest hair maintenance in the studio
we' have opinions would have a great
opinion on this Jade's not
here to sh boom roasted
Jade hey Jade spends more time on her
hair than you do I promise you I've got
this down to a sience she's got more
stuff going on from the Predator look to
the twisted up on top look to the whole
thing she's got more looks tell you this
I haven't spent 13 Grand on my hair so
there's bonus yeah none of all of us
together have not spent 13 Grand on our
hair so that's a lot I would just start
wearing hats or just let it ride man I
mean you got a great head for it Dave a
not everyone has that see George you're
trying to dig out now you're trying to
dig out never dig out get you a shovel
buddy this is my last show America it's
been good shovel buddy it's been fun
yeah you you and Austin Austin brings in
the hair joke email an alop and you just
you you you do the stuff with it right
you just stuff the thing right yeah all
right let's move on while I still have
my job all right Sarah is in Nashville
hi Sarah welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi thanks for having me sure what's
up okay so I work two jobs I work a
full-time job and then I also work a
part-time job um my question is should I
or like is it okay for me to quit my
part-time job um even though I'm in baby
step to um the reason I'm wanting to
quit it is basically because I'm working
at all all the time you know I'm trying
to be gazelle intense and all but I am
not having a good time and I want to
pursue like other things to eventually
go into that so like what are you
saying basically I want to in the long
run get into music and I am in Nashville
so it's like the perfect place to do
that you want to get into music did you
say yes okay all right but and what's
your part-time gig now I'm in retail
okay all right well that's like most of
Nashville yeah I mean like how do you
get the next country music stars
attention in Nashville uh
waiter right I mean that that's they're
everywhere I've got I've got three
people that were on The Voice working
for me and they ain't doing voice I'm
telling you so um but anyway the uh uh
yeah it's it's everywhere and I'm not
saying you can't do it you you should do
it but how much debt do you have left
I about
50,000 and it's student loans okay and
when will at your current rate with
gazelle intensity when will that be
done um about 2ish years how old are you
28 okay how many hours a week are you
working
now um about 15 hours extra
so and plus a 40-hour job yes okay so
where do you work on Saturday night
um so retail retail is not
open yeah correct so I'm not working
yeah where do you work on Friday night
not at retail it's not
open well I work the retail job uh
Monday through Friday after work and
they close all right so you don't have a
Saturday gig okay yeah so sing on
Saturday yeah so I guess it's a little
bit complicated because I'm not into
like the country music scene more into
Christian you're in Nashville and you
want to get into music you want to be in
the Christian music is that what you
said yes okay so how are you planning on
breaking into
it that's a good question I'm not quite
exactly sure I'm more thinking like the
social media route okay then I would do
that on
Saturdays okay and I get plugged into a
church where that music is happening as
well yeah make sure you're in a good
church that's Musical and they're doing
a lot of good praise and worship stuff
and you know Nashville is also the home
of contemporary Christian music for sure
most of the artists live here that do
that for a living a lot of them are
friends uh the older ones are friends
Darren Tyler did a songwriting night at
his church with a bunch of songwriters
so there's stuff like this happening in
the community all the time you can do
all of that and still keep your retail
job you just got to give up partying on
Saturday oh wait a minute you're doing
this from a Christian perspective maybe
partying isn't the problem um you got to
shut down the prayer group on Saturday
night and go do something else kind of
party yeah that's it so yeah I I think
you can find the time Sarah and I think
it's a short-term play to get out of
debt let's get out of
[Music]
[Applause]
debt
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Walt is in Buffalo New
York hey Walt welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey guys thanks for taking my call I
appreciate it sure what's up uh actually
had two questions but the young lady on
the the screener told me I could only
ask one so I figur I'd mention it maybe
you guys let me squeak in too uh my wife
and I have been on the baby steps since
no November of
2022 we made it all the way to step
three and almost immediately after that
we had to use a couple thousand doll of
our emergency
fund uh we have
$4,000 in a high yield savings account
that's earmarked for kids college uh
he's 10 right now and we're wondering if
we should take the 2,000 from that four
to fill the emergency fund back
up I
would uh because it's not in a college
fund it's just earmarked you you have
two accounts one of them you got named
college but you got a 10-year-old you
got plenty of time to build their
college savings and doing it in a 529
and so forth that's exactly what I would
do yeah simple enough I mean it's liquid
you're not going to pay any penalties so
if you told me it was in a 529 I'd say
don't touch it yeah but you're you'll be
fine there and you'll have time to fill
it back or if it had been there for 20
years years or something and the kid was
seven I mean you know there's a lot of
different factors but uh you got a lot
of time and it's just a it's just a
right pocket left pocket thing um and
then just you know if you take it out of
the right pocket put in the left pocket
then you got to go back to the right
pocket and fill it up which is baby step
five anyway reminder while four five and
six are done
simultaneously yep so we're investing
15% while we have that plate spinning we
begin to fund the kids college then any
money left over we can throw onto the
mortgage to pay that off early yeah so
four five and six which is retirement
savings kids college savings and paying
the house off early we run
simultaneously but still in that order
15% going into retirement funding kids
college which you're going to do
immediately uh you'll begin with that
with that 2,000 it's left over and get
an account open and get it moving and
then if you find more money in your
budget or as you find more money in your
budget as you go along let's pay off the
house early Elijah is with us in
Charlotte North Carolina Hi Elijah
welcome to the Rams
show hey Dave thanks for having us sure
what's
up so me and my wife have a question and
it is we are debt free we have an
emergency fund we've tried to do
everything by the book and both of us
have zero credit and we are renting
currently is there any way that we could
one day buy a house without any credit
what is your
advice well George did it yeah it's a a
fairly simple process it's called manual
underwriting and what that is is
basically a no score loan and our
friends at Churchill Mortgage have been
doing this forever but if you tell
anyone about it they'll say no you can't
do that and even if they say you can
they'll say it's so much more expensive
it's such a headache it'll take you
forever they're lying they've never done
it so let me tell you from someone who's
done it that it's simple but you have to
do it by the book like you mentioned so
you're going to want to have all the
documentation your verification of
income rental payment history you know
12-month history of your bank statements
a tax return things like that and along
with that you need to have a good down
payment have you guys started saving
that up
yet yes as soon as we finish building up
our emergency fund that's what we were
going to start on awesome so I would aim
to have a minimum of 10% if you're doing
the no score loan 20% is even better to
avoid that private mortgage insurance
what kind of budget are you looking for
for a
house right now we're in North Carolina
and the housing market can wear from 100
or $200,000 to
$300,000 great so let's set that goal
and set it down payment savings goal and
as long as you can get that payment to
be 25% of your take-home pay of your
after tax income per month on a 15year
fixed then you're ready to buy a
home sounds great thank you so much
again Elijah if you go to a traditional
mortgage company or you ask your
friends um they're all going to tell you
that because they don't know how to do
it that that can't be done George did it
Jade did it Dr John deloney did it all
of our Ramsey personalities have had
zero credit scores and G and got
mortgages okay so it it definitely can
be done we'll put a link to uh the
Ramsey Solutions blog about this in the
show notes and so if you want to go back
and pull that up out of the show notes
you'll be able to do that with a great
detail on it but really George just gave
it all to you and again selecting a
mortgage company that knows what the
flip they're doing that's important and
most of them don't Church Hill mortgage
does know how to do this Chaz is with us
in Orlando hi Chaz welcome to the Ramsey
Show hey Dave thanks for having me sure
what's up
uh so my question is I'm 24 years old me
and my fiance are getting married next
February um I have zero debt right now
um and I have a nice little NES egg in
the bank that I've been saving up um my
question is my fiance has some debt once
we get married do you recommend that I
kind of use up most of my Nest Egg to
pay off her debt or should we keep that
Nest EG in the bank and just keep
pursuing paying off her debt now that we
go have both incomes to pay it
off what are we talking in the
bank so right now I have about $34,000
in the bank um and then her debt is a
little bit over
$117,000 okay um so it wouldn't totally
wipe it out but it's just you know we
now through February it's just you know
no I don't know what do you mean you
know for I mean yeah but like we just
like to have it in the bank no you do
just like yes you worked hard to save
this money up and it hurts emotionally
to Let It Go for someone else's
mistake yeah that's okay to say out loud
but just know when you get married
you're signing up for that whole
person's life and it's our money so now
you have debt as well it's our debt and
it's our income all of the mistakes you
have made come with you all of the
mistakes she has made come with her and
the preacher will say and now you are
one
mistake so so this is how this works
brother are you that in love with her
that you're willing to do this oh 100%
not even a second get home from the
honeymoon write a check and pay off for
student
loan okay yeah period period no question
about it and she should be paying it
down you know we've got to save up for
the wedding are you guys paying for
it no luckily her parents have blessed
us with paying for the wedding great so
that's been a huge blessing for sure
wonder and she's totally she's paying
paying it down we actually been taking
your class through our church and good
so she's already working it down like
every single day um but it's just it
looks like there might be a little bit
left over once we get married and so you
know I was calling in to see see what
your opinion was on so Chaz here's the
thing if you called us up you you've
listened to us or you've been through
Financial Peace University if you called
us up and said we're a married couple we
have $34,000 in savings and we have
$177,000 in a student
loan we instantaneously would tell you
to pay that off would wouldn't
we yes you would okay the only Nuance
here is is that it's new because the
marriage will be at that time new so
that's the only nuance and what you're
facing here is you're really having to
face this idea that we are going to
combine our incomes our dreams our fears
our mistakes our assets we're going to
combine everything and we're going to
become a whole new entity called a
married couple and that and you're
you're this is forcing you to process
the emotions of that which to George's
Point are you know we we poke fun but
but it's they're very real it's a very
real emotion yeah and so but you've
listened to us enough to know that if
you were answering the question as
you're driving along in the car while
listening on talk radio uh and someone
else called in you would be going
they're going to tell him to pay the
loan
off yes true so the only difference here
is it wasn't an existing marriage couple
were moving into it and that's the only
Nuance to change it happens to be your
money this time rather than listening to
someone else to call in that changes it
too that's tough but you know the
beautiful thing is you also get to build
wealth together and it is like
exponentially greater when you have two
people who are on the same page oh yeah
yeah that there's what's called in uh
sociological studies and economic
studies that called the marriage
Advantage h the P you know the there's
several marital advantages uh if you
haven't read the the research that's out
there uh Health me males who are married
live longer wow yeah uh and couples who
are married have a wealth and an income
career career and income Advantage
statistically they make more money and
they have more money statistically so
it's called the marriage Advantage
research projects that are out there
floating around very interesting to look
at so yeah you're right this is going to
go zoom zoom you're going to be fine
that puts this hour of the Ramsey Show
in the
[Music]
books hey it's George camel if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsey Baby Steps go to ramseys
solutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's Ramy
solutions.com and click get
[Music]
started live from the headquarters of
ramsy solutions it's the Ramsey show
where we help people build wealth do
work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships George camel
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
I'm Dave Ramsey the phone number is
88255 225 starting off this hour is
Corey in Cleveland Ohio hi Corey how are
you good how are you doing better than I
deserve what's up so I got a question I
I got 35,000 in credit card debt I'm
going through a divorce uh she wants me
to take another half of hers and I um I
I'm struggling I'm working um five days
a week um I drive truck as a local truck
driver and I just don't know where to
where even to start
at okay
um how much debt do you guys have as a
couple you've got 35 how much does she
have it'll be 65,000 total so she has
another 30 yes okay and there car
payments uh yes I have a car payment my
my truck payment is 970 a month good God
all right and um how much is her car
payment uh her car payment I'm not too
sure that we're actually we're going
through a divorce and we're separated at
this
time well dude you were married to her
did you have the car
then yeah yeah well she had uh she had
given me my car back I had bought her a
Lexus at the time and she had give it
back to me stuck me with that and my
truck payment plus a motorcycle payment
and I was struggling so I traded both of
my vehicles in and end up purchasing the
truck I have now I saved myself about
$500 a month doing that yeah you didn't
go far enough all right no I didn't all
right
um okay so the problem is is we're
working out all the debts before there's
a deal cut MH so every time you every
time you get something paid off or
figured out she hands you another one
yes now this has got to
stop you've already eaten a Lexus in a
motorcycle and now she wants you to eat
15 more of the debt that's the credit
card debt that's in her name yes okay so
we need to uh do you guys have an
attorney yeah we have we both have
attorneys I I tried toner I I she keep
the house and everything we put into it
she keeps her debt I keep mine we'll go
our separate ways she's not into it she
has no she's not willing to work with me
at
all okay then I guess the judge is going
to have to decide right and that goes
February 7th I'm trying to figure out
what I need to do in the meantime I have
an opportunity right now to buy my own
semi and go over the road and make what
I'm making now no you need to get this
cleared up before you do that because
she's gonna end up with half the dad gum
semi right that's what I'm worried about
yeah how much money do you have in the
bank uh at this moment in time I'm
struggling and that's why but um I have
maybe 30 bucks right now I'm going
through it right now
MH
okay and you're not driving over the
road now or you
are you just cut out on me man uh that's
why we were uh that's why we're going to
the divorce we drove team over the road
together me and her together uh we were
racking down 250,000 a year between us
both um I was sticking mine in my 401k
she was spending hers and that's another
thing she's wanting she's wanting half
of my 401k also and we weren't even
married that long three years and she's
entitled to uh everything I put in from
the date of marriage to the date of
divorce which is it's not even it's not
really a lot of money but I worked for
it you know you guys have kids no kids
nope okay so are you driving over the
road now no I'm local okay what do you
make uh right now now I'm 3322 an hour
and that is all straight pay and you've
got an apartment yes okay what's the
house
worth uh I just had an appraise at
appraise for
174,000 what do you owe on
it uh
132 okay all right so here's here's what
I would do all right the problem with a
divorce is it turns a marriage into a
business
transaction and so this is now a list of
debts and a list of assets that must be
negotiated through the law in Most
states as you have found out splits it
down the middle what she wants doesn't
matter what you want doesn't matter the
law is going to demand that you split it
down the middle if you come to something
close to that and pre- agree to it the
judge will approve it if you come to
something way out of balance the judge
is probably not going to approve it and
kick out your agreed to to settlement
because it's too
stupid okay so all of that to say you
don't need to be buying anything if I
were in your shoes I'd sell this
truck yeah get you yeah you said that
like I'm not doing it you need to sell
your stupid truck dude $970 at $33 an
hour is in the cray cray zone right I I
want to get rid of it I went to trade it
in they told me I would have to pay out
$4,000 in equity negative equity to cck
get off from underneath the truck at
that point
It Go Go borrow 4,000 at the credit
union and do it or sell a private party
if you can make 4,000 more and be get
out of it clean sell it private and and
just sell it and be done with it
somebody will give you more than you owe
on it okay what is it what kind of truck
is it it's a 2023 Chevy
Silverado that's a beast that's a good
Truck Yeah you ought to be able to get
more than you owe on it yeah so yeah the
problem is a dealer thinks he's got you
coming
again right he got you last time he's
going to get you again especially if
you're desperate they can smell that off
of you yeah so I think I think you put
it on the look it up on Kelly Blue Book
and sell it for more than you owe on it
and then get you a hoopie because you're
driving truck during the day anyway you
don't need a bank big car right now you
got more problems than you need car
right yes sir so this is temporary one
year from the day everything's going to
be changed but temporarily you've gotten
rid of the car now you're down to only
$35,000 worth a credit card debt and
negotiating with your soon Tobe ex-wife
over the 401K in the house yes cuz the
credit card debt is going to be split
down the middle you're going to get your
35 she's going to get her 30 you're
probably going to give up half your 401k
or you can give her a credit towards the
house and sell the
house right how much is in the
401K uh 35 35,000 so 17 of the equity in
the house can go to her instead of
giving up your 401k and sell the house
and give her her half plus 17 which is
probably almost the whole thing but
don't let the house stay in the deal do
not don't do not let her have the house
because you're on the mortgage and then
she doesn't pay it you're
screwed right Force the sale of the
house split the proceeds minus your half
of the 401K that you're going to have to
give up anyway and that way your 401k
stays
intact yes you walk out of this with a
401k and only $35,000 with a credit card
debt and a hoopie now you can talk about
going over the
road and making some money and clean up
the 35,000 right
quick okay but you're being managed by
emotion because your heart's broken one
minute you're pissed the next minute and
you're broken terrified the next minute
yes sir I understand man I've been there
it's no fun and so I I Haven been
through the divorce part of it been
through the rest of it though and it is
no fun so laying out a detailed factual
game plan with math remove some of the
emotion from it and that's what I just
gave you so go back and listen to this
on YouTube or on podcast or however so I
because I gave you the exact plan of
what to do and and what I what I laid
out is negotiable and if she won't do it
take it before the judge he'll make her
do it this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
so one of the most popular things we
have done in many years is about 2
months ago we started doing
free webinars
with Jade warshaw Rachel Cruz and George
camel each of them doing free webinars
with the every dollar budgeting app
showing you how to build out your budget
why to build out your budget and uh
couples are jumping on for free and
watching the webinar and you can
interact with the webinar you can
actually ask questions live live chat a
Q&A Box live chat while we're going and
a what box a Q&A box box so you thr
stuff so there's interaction it's not
just George squawking at you or Jade or
Jade or Rachel's walking at you and uh
so we're doing these free online
budgeting trainings uh go to
everydollar.com
budgeting and between now and the end of
the year each one of those three will be
doing three or four of these and so
George Rachel Jade uh you can jump on
choose which one or just pick the night
or day or whatever that the time is
convenient for you it's completely free
very interactive very helpful on the
every dooll bud budgeting app on how to
get a plan together cuz if you don't
have a plan you know it's like Zig
Ziggler used to say if you aim at
nothing you'll hit it every time and my
friend John Maxwell says a budget is
people telling their money what to do
instead of wondering where it went every
doll.com budgeting get registered for
the free webinars George what do they
get if they go to yours well we give
away stuff and uh that's I like to bribe
people with that so we'll give away some
stuff we have a a killer you really are
you just making a no we really do we've
given away U I already give away your
services I know we gave away some books
and products and things like that for
those that are brave enough to ask a
question in front of you know 3,000
virtual people CU that's there is a cap
even though it's digital they cap the
room size so you got to make sure you
sign up we'll also send you a replay if
you miss it a lot of people say hey I
can't make that time sign up anyways you
can go back and watch the whole thing
there you go and free stuff for the
people that do attend and ask a question
and you bribe people for their
involvement you got but people do get
really interactive I've heard the stor
yeah we've had great feedback back just
showing them we don't have time on the
air to show you how it all works but
that webinar is where we do it Olivia is
in Madison Wisconsin hi Olivia welcome
to the Ramsey
Show hi Dave hi George thank you for
taking my call sure what's up um so my
question is about student loans um I
currently have um a um I have around
three let's see
105,000 in student loans um and it's
broken up between um a private uh
University Foundation loan and then
Federal loans um and my question is um
the the Federal Loan is broken up into
smaller loans yes um some of them are
subsidized some are unsubsidized yes and
so my question is how do I prioritize
that do I or do I just pay the private
and then the
federal I'll tell you how I did did it
10 years ago I laid them all out from
smallest balance to largest balance
that's called the debt snowball method
and I ignore the interest rates just
black them out if you have to because it
gets real confusing and overwhelming and
all you do is you focus on that smallest
balance first my guess is it's one of
those little Federal
loans yes what's the smallest balance
you
got um I believe the smallest one is
about five or 6,000 of one of the the
Federal loans yeah what do you
make um my husband and I make um about
115 great so how quick you gonna pay
that five
off oh we can pay the five off in um
probably couple months Max yeah or more
I was think two paychecks yeah okay
quick quick quick how yeah all of these
um Federal loans are under one service
you need to call them you need to pay
the minimums and then call them and get
them on the phone which is a pain in the
butt because they're incompetent but
call them and get them on the phone and
demand that the money you transfer right
then goes on that loan because if you
mail it to them or you make it one check
for all the minimums and that they will
screw it up and spread it across all of
them because they're
incompetent okay up until now we've just
been paying um what across all across
all of them yeah and nothing happens
yeah you don't see any movement but I
want that little one knocked out cu when
that little one's knocked out your
payment
changes okay and drop down and then more
and more and more the debt snowball
rolls but if you don't knock out the
little one then the Deb snowball doesn't
roll meaning every time you pay off
something that has a payment with the
debt snowball that old payment now gives
you extra money to throw on the next one
but if the old payment is zero then it
doesn't give you any extra money to
throw on the next one so you got to call
them and each stinking month make sure
they're doing the right one the right
one the right one when you're on one of
the little small
federals yeah and you can also see
online it may break them out you may be
able to apply that to the principle but
I'm not sure if these websites if you
can be if you can make sure on the
website you could try it one month and
see if it drops the principal on that
singular debt rather than spread across
all of them but I got to tell you
they're it's the worst it's the federal
government I mean user experience the
incompetence of the IRS the incompetence
of the federal government shows up here
like you never believe these people's
parents are cousins it's just awful
they're just horrible and so uh it's a
it's a disaster the whole student loan
debacle is a disaster So the faster you
get it in the rearview mirror the better
your life is going to be good question
thanks for joining us Miguel is in San
Antonio hi Miguel welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi daavid and George how youall
doing better than we deserve what's up
that's right um so I'm 22 years old U I
have a car payment at sitting at 10,000
left to be paid off that's the only debt
I have um originally the car started at
18,000 I had it for two years and so
I've been trying to pay it down much
ahead of time to so I can get that
completely finished out um and I do have
the money to pay it off right now I
could pay it off today but that is
pretty much everything that I have so
you ow you owe how much
today uh today it's it's just under
10,000 it's at 9,000 okay and how much
money do you
have um
I have 12,000 right now do you so I
would still have I make around 40,000 a
year good and what other debt do you
have other than the stupid
car I don't have any other debt good pay
it off today man it leaves you with what
three grand and no car payment yeah and
and and that doesn't include my um
emergency fund I still have an emergency
F of a thousand okay no no no you're
starter emergency fund you're starter so
now you got three you got three grand
four grand yeah and now you your next
goal is to build that four grand up to 3
to 6 months of expenses which in your
case is probably about a $10,000
emergency
fund okay and without a car payment
you'll get there even faster
yeah yeah it's so with that yes that I
should pay it off um one more thing I'd
like to add on to the story now is that
I am engaged congratulations a wedding
when when's the
wedding uh we just signed the contract
for two years almost exactly two years
so two years long ways away man why two
years um my my fiance is still going
through graduate school and I actually
work at a university so she's going to
be able to get graduate school paid for
with uh my benefit there not if you're
not
married the blessing we are planning to
get married legally first and then so
that she can get that
benefit and then we're going to have a
wedding in the church because we are uh
Catholic and we do want
to get married in the church okay so
what does the Catholic Church charge you
to get
married well we wanted we've been dating
for six years and we wanted to we've had
a lot of different people come to our
lives been a part of our story we wanted
to have something um so we have a budget
of around 20 to
25,000 and and with it being just me
right now you're talking about actually
getting married when
legally 20 legally would be
um pretty much the beginning of 2024 in
February okay and then then then your
husband and wife the other things you're
just going to have a
party exactly okay and so you're going
to save up for a $220,000 party I don't
give a flip when you have your $20,000
party you can have that whenever you
want you're now husband and wife and you
have a paid for car tada
it doesn't change anything dude matter
of fact it it actually makes it more
sense for you to pay off the thing today
with that combined income $10,000 is not
going for the party two years from now
for sure while you have a stinking car
payment you're going to save up new
money to pay for the party or not this
is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America Jacob and Taylor are on the debt
free stage in the lobby of ramsy
solutions how are you well great how are
you better than I deserve welcome where
do you guys live so we're from Tulsa
Oklahoma oh fun welcome to Nashville how
much debt did you pay so we paid off
about
182,000 good for you how long did that
take too long but about eight years okay
good and and uh what was your range of
income during that time so we started
about 70,000 7075 and then up to about5
cool what do youall do for a living so
I'm a mechanic at Alexa Steeler in Tulsa
M uh after I graduated college I ended
up in the nonprofit field for about
seven and a half years uh but now I'm a
stay-at-home dog Mom I have a network
marketing business and I'm a part-time
braa okay good for you cool all right
what kind of debt was the
182,000 so it was student loan for her
and then and then our mortgage oh paid
off your house look at them weird people
I love that so what is this house worth
in Tulsa it's worth about 280 now way to
go guys nice house we're seeing it on
YouTube here nice picture yeah and it's
all yours all ours how old how old are
you two weirdos so I'm 33 I just turned
32 last week you have a paid for house
do you know anyone that's 33 with a paid
for house other than George he was a
huge inspiration for us very very big
that means the world well I'm amazed
that this trend keeps happening I feel
like we're seeing it more and more their
20 30s late 20s early 30s coming in here
with a paid off house definitely yeah
we're it's very exciting do you know I
mean any of your friend group got a paid
for house I don't think so not that I
know of yeah they'd be talking about it
if they did yeah that's true very true
they'd be here too where did this idea
even come from how did you guys get
started on this ramay way eight years
ago yeah yeah good question uh so right
after I graduated college is when we got
married married and we actually got
Financial Peace University membership as
a wedding gift and so I'd love to give a
shout out to Tracy a family friend who
gifted that to us and that changed
everything for our family so we took it
about 3 months after we got married and
I remember sitting there the second or
third week and and I was like we have to
teach this like we people need to know
about this and so we went through the
class and um we kind of did things a
little a little out of order we actually
like bought our home during the class
but turns out we did it right we put 20%
down it's a 15year loan all of that so
all of that was right but then we um you
know ventured on the the student loan
and we got that done it was 38,000 and
we got that done in 22 months good so we
knocked that out pretty quickly and so
um right after that class was over we
started teaching um so we've coordinated
uh nearly 15 classes now super thank you
we love it absolutely love it super
coordinators you got to follow the stuff
at that point the whole class is look at
you have you led one since paying off
the house um we had one this summer so
we got to celebrate with them and then
we'll have another one in January so
really kept us accountable you know
working with each of the classes and and
sharing our story and all of that so
it's like your personal trainer having a
six-pack like this is a good sign I'm in
the right place when I'm in your class
way to go yes we're excited so we um in
a lot of ways I guess a huge part of our
story is um you know we've had
emergencies come up just like anybody
else
um we've replaced our AC unit had a for
night Hospital stay and we also Jacob is
working on his bachelor's and so we're
cash flowing that and so that's part of
the reason why maybe it's taken a little
bit longer and what are you studying
Jacob uh mechanical engineering oh very
good okay how much longer do you have uh
about a year oh wow good for you that's
going to be a great breakthrough for you
yeah but it's been a been almost
fiveyear process so but all part time
yeah exactly so and as newlyweds we've
we've done a lot lot of traveling um
we've done a couple of international
trips we've been all over the United
States but all with cash all without
credit cards um and so that certainly
has you know extended our um you know
our our deadline I guess but the goal
was always to pay off for home seven
years early yeah um and that's exactly
what we did so hit the goal we did it's
been really exciting really well once
you're out of baby steps 2 and three
travel is allowed it just slows down you
slows down how much you put on baby step
six or buying a car is allowed or going
the Schools allowed it just slows down
how much you put on baby step 6 but you
still did all of that and did the house
in seven years yes that's pretty cool
yeah we sure did it's been been fun it's
been living proof this stuff still works
yes exactly every day yeah and in a lot
of ways too um Jacob and I are both
natural givers um and so outside of our
mortgage our giving category and our
budget was actually one of the largest
and so we were kind of practicing baby
step seven even kind of before we got
there so so you know the travel and and
the the giving part of that you know we
give to things that we're passionate
about we just couldn't wait to do that
so amen good for you yeah good for you
okay now how's it feel when you walk
through the backyard and you don't have
any
payments feels nice it really does I
mean you don't we don't necessarily like
worried if that payment was going to be
there the first of the month but it's
nice not having to like even having to
worry about that have y'all walked back
in the backyard and stood and looked at
the house and went that's ours mhm we
have actually
yes yes front back walk through the
grass Barefoot yeah pictures neighbors
are going what are they doing over
exactly yes they do a lot of celebrating
over there I don't know that's good good
for you what do you tell people in your
class the secret to getting out of dead
is oh man number one on my list is
tithing that's been just the Forefront
of our mind and why do you think that is
man when you live life like this you
know it it's just better than opened yes
yeah it's just better than you can than
you can dream or imagine and so uh
blessings have come from that and and
certainly you know since we have led 15
Financial Peace University classes we
watch the videos 15 times and so um you
know just keeping up with that and and
having a group to walk through that with
has been a really crucial part so yeah
the accountability and the
open-handedness yeah what about you
Jacob I think it's a lot of it is not
living above your means I mean that
we've you know not been in any kind of
dire straight situation but we've also
not like saying oh I need to go into
debt for to do this or I need to put
this money towards the trip and not pay
off what we need to pay off so I think
it's it's knowing what you need as
opposed to just what you want yeah it's
intentionality right yeah yeah way to go
guys I'm so proud of you thank you who
was uh who was cheering you on everybody
everybody yeah um a lot of a lot of my
parents instilled a lot of this into
into me from the get-go so they've
always been kind of of that driving
force for for me especially not before
we got married and then since since
we've been married they've been you know
a constant cheerleading team um so and
then her grandma and then our our
friends you know who who know that we're
on this journey or were on this journey
you know they've always been super
supportive and our church family our
community group you know we we've we
surrounded by a huge support team wow
that's awesome that makes a big
difference yeah and you guys are in your
early 30s you got no payments give me
something you're excited to do in the
save spend category with no payments now
yeah for sure yeah I mean making our our
giving budget a little bit larger now uh
we're updating our home so like you know
updating the outdoor space and replacing
Windows things like that adulting
adulting exactly yeah so that's any big
trips now you're like this is the big
debt-free
trip yeah uh actually next May we're
going to go to Italy so we actually uh
at a fundraising Gala prior to covid we
uh won this went a trip through a silent
auction and Co kind of ruined that a
little bit um couldn't go well now we
are 3 years on from it we're actually
going to get to go on it and even in a
better Financial place than we were then
to go so that's that we're going to kind
of use that as our celebratory yeah good
that's awesome it's a good trip well
done y'all that's fun yes well
congratulations we're very proud of you
we've got the Liv and give bundle for
you because you've been doing a lot of
both living and giving so uh baby steps
Millionaire's book you'll be there very
soon if you're not already I didn't ask
how much you have in retirement how much
do you have in retirement we probably
have I'm think we have probably about
100 Grand now with ir you said the house
is worth 300 close to it yeah so you're
about 400 of the million almost on your
you're on your way to Baby Steps
Millionaire right good way yeah we got
that book for you that's your next step
and next stop and Total Money Makeover
book maybe to give to one of your class
members and a Financial Peace University
membership if you find somebody that
can't go will assist you in your giving
uh your generosity plunge that you're
taking that's awesome so congratulations
you guys all right Jacob and Taylor
Tulsa Oklahoma 182,000 paid off house
and everything count it down let's hear
a debt-free Scream 3 2 one we're dead
[Applause]
free
w wow excellent
excellent this is the Ramsey
[Music]
[Laughter]
shot
[Music]
our scripture of the day James 1 2 and 3
consider it pure joy my brothers and
sisters whenever you face Trials of many
kinds because you know that the testing
of your faith produces
perseverance Franklin Roosevelt said
when you're at the end of your rope tie
a knot and hold on Amen Kristen is with
us in Madison Wisconsin hi Kristen
welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi Dave hi George thank you so much
for taking my call sure what's
up um so my husband and I were newly
married uh we just finished baby step
one this month uh we have
$45,000 in Consumer Debt and baby step 2
and as we're laying them out smallest to
largest we also have some other pretty
big expenses that aren't necessarily
debt and we're just having a hard time
figuring out where they should fall in
our snowball what are they we have um so
we have two vehicles one of them we own
outright one of them we have a loan for
$6,200 and the one that we have a loan
on is broken down um the rear
differential is completely seized up
it's not drivable it's going to be about
a $2,000 fix we're hoping to eventually
fix it and then sell it to get rid of it
um also we bought a house at the
beginning of this year and two weeks
after we closed on our house the pipes
in the bathroom burst and so that is
currently completely gutted we don't
have a shower uh sink um we in that
bathro at all uh that's the only
bathroom we have in our house so we've
been showering at our mother-in-law's
house um we've been going over there to
do that for how long and then um for
about 6 months seven
months yeah she's two blocks away which
is great she's super close but it's
there's nothing great about this this
sucks oh my gosh what a mess and we you
ins wouldn't cover it um well that's the
other part I lost my job recently So
currently my husband is working y need
to write a country song an hour we
showered my mother-in-laws and I lost my
job yeah it's there's a lot wow so
what's he
making he's making $18 an hour right now
doing
what uh he's a machine operator what
were you
making I was making uh 60k I was a
restaurant
manager why'd you lose your
job um I was working in a restaurant um
I loved my job the hours were not great
I was working 60 to 70 hours a week
salary so I took a different position in
the same it was another restaurant
manager position and I moved over to
that it was going to be 45 hours a week
um and that would salary also so that
would allow me a little more time um but
uh a couple weeks into that they decided
that I was not a good fit um and they
let me go when was
that that was uh that was in June why
haven't you worked since
June well that's the other thing my
husband um he
uh had his driver's license suspended
and the car broke down um so we were
able why did he have his driver's
license suspended I can't believe
this it's been suspended for um for
quite a while he had to wait a couple
years um there was a period of time DUI
for the points yeah and then for the
points to fall off and so he can he's
eligible to get it reinstated now but it
is it's about $800 to pay all the fees
and for everything and then our
insurance would go up okay so your
excuse is you're a full-time driver for
an $18 an hour guy I'm calling bull
crap that was a dumb idea you make more
than he
makes yeah and so we were able to share
um we were working in the same town we
were driving yeah back when but now with
him being yeah yeah but now with you not
having a job you used driving him as an
excuse to not get a job so get another
job girl couldn't you drop him and then
go work and then pick him up or he gets
a ride there's a lot what you did
before yeah so we were um I can I'm
looking at getting I've been doing um
applying for jobs there were a couple I
got to the second interview um
restaurant manager positions and um you
know they ended up really not going
anywhere but now what I'm looking at is
um what would be wrong with M working 60
hours a week
now
what was wrong with it then you were
broke yeah
um it was mostly the schedule and
driving back and forth and not being
available to pick him up because I had
to stay late to solve a problem at work
and um so you lost $60,000 because he
didn't buy an
Uber yeah yeah you need you guys need to
you guys need to both be committed to 60
to 80 hours a week making $20 an hour
and you will solve a lot of these
problems you have in a heartbeat instead
you're living in a house that's not even
habitable because you don't even have a
toilet or a
shower and you haven't worked since June
you guys have got to go create some
money girl you went from 100K down to 36
and you got 45 in debt so if we get you
back to work is not your problem your
income the the fact you guys don't make
any money is your problem and you don't
work much
yeah you both need he needs a new job he
needs a new job making 25 an hour and
two extra jobs making 20 an hour and you
need the 60 70 80 hour a week 60 to
80,000 to be the restaurant manager job
and buy an Uber if you're stuck at work
I mean can you wait tables in the
meantime
yes um so that's what our next plan was
I can pay $125 to reinstate my CNA I
have to go take the the test but then I
would be able to get my CNA license back
and that's I'm sorry what is a CNA
license what is a CNA license CER
certified nurse
assistant and what would that
pay uh $25 an
hour 20 why would you want to do that
when you can make 60 as broke as you are
why don't you go get you some
money I I've been applying for
restaurant manager positions I had two
where I went to the second interview
second interview uh process um I've
applied for for more than those but
those are the ones where I was um
interviewed and you guys need to sit
down you guys need to sit down and
figure out the way on the short term not
what your dream is but the thing you can
do that is moral and legal that allows
you all to work the most hours and make
the most money for about two years so
you can get your shower fixed and get
your debt paid off but you're not going
to do it with all these theories
in all these limitations and you're
finding all kinds of reasons to not do
this stuff um really honestly 50 Grand
solves your whole
life 50,000 bucks you could have made
that since
June if he was working overtime and you
were still working and so you really
have an
income that your perception of work and
your perception of income on a temporary
basis needs to change
that is your issue because you guys need
to BU you know $18 and I mean in a in a
world where most people are making 25 to
30 okay uh and no you don't go get a CNA
to make $25 an hour when you have the
income potential of 60 to 880,000 at a
restaurant and in the meantime until you
land that you go get six jobs and you
guys work your tail ends off I'm fixing
my freaking toilet and my shower this is
crazy y'all go make some money girl we
want you to win but you you you guys
spend a lot of your mental the in
talking to you there's a lot of mental
gymnastics on how why we can't create an
income there was a lot of them I mean
you're like a a world class gymnast well
I know life has happened to you I know
it has but got stuck in your head and
you got this Loop going and I'm trying
to force you even if you get mad at me
I'm doing that because I love you I'm
trying to force you to rethink your view
on work well every question that was
well there's a story behind I know but
we at some point we just have to put it
down and do it anyways and go to work
anyways do the job we don't want to do
anyways yeah exactly yeah you your
$50,000 changes your whole life you
could go make 50 to 100,000 more than
you made in the last 12 months in the
next 12 months between the two of you
changing your view on work that's how
that's how fast your life can turn
around and and the desperation that you
feel every day when you go to your
mother-in-laws to take a shower will go
away that puts us hour of the Ramsey
Show in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the Prince of Peace Christ
[Music]
Jesus do you love a good day brand want
to see the latest Ramsey Show videos
going viral check out your favorite
moments from the Ramsey Show on YouTube
go watch And subscribe to the Ramsey
Show Channel on
[Music]
YouTube